so brendan you sent this to us there was
a whole catfishing thing with a missing
girl oh my god i'm gonna get into it
you got it's so [ __ ] good it's so
good
so check this out so i'll read
barstool's caption says a well-known uh
when a well-known lakers podcast host
went missing her co-host tweeted asking
for help
and nba twitter stepped up and found out
she's been a catfish the whole time
for years what they think is this this
dude
has been portraying himself as the host
and the co-host
so he'll like talk change his voice he's
the woman
and even the woman to laugh at like his
bad jokes and goes back and forth and
they
so she went for whatever reason i don't
know why he did this
so hey lakers family look vivian flores
is missing
may or may not be wearing a wig because
she's going
through leukemia and all this [ __ ] what
it's
nuts dude keep scrolling down that's
what she looks like
that's what she looks like so fans got
involved and found out that this lady's
actually
i guess she can do something with a app
where you can change the face and take
the face put on something they found out
this
this girl's been honey-dicking everybody
so there it is
so scroll up so it says this them
breaking down bar stool did great job
sunday night uh tassant sends out some
wearing tweets flores was missing
uh so tassant is the co-host yeah
florence is missing and her family's
asking to help find her so he posts that
right love you all stay safe let us know
if you find her
so keep going and then uh
even uh [ __ ] ice cubes son goes no
way are you serious everyone please
retweet this anywhere in the air
she's so such a dope person let's find
her so it's like oh damn it's real keep
going and then la lakers
absolutely vivian is part of the family
how nuts
i read this whole thing it's insane and
it's [ __ ] nice and she's not even
so then even uh kevin garnett got
involved
it's uh it's fairly long about to play a
clip of it so i guess this guy big kings
was fooled by the same person vivian
flores before so kevin durant's asking
how
how are you falling for this whatever so
he actually being catfish and this thing
called
twitter space i don't know what it is
it's like because i guess too they found
out that they sort of they found out
that this catfish
guy or girl whoever's doing it did this
back in the day for the
readers a bunch of different things same
picture everything for the raiders
oh so i played this real quick this is
insane oh yeah it's not and
it was uh it was locked in y'all slow
down for a second
all right so so you're saying who the
hell is king
the [ __ ] right there big kings
hey you better not call them big kings
again
right there man come on so you're saying
he got so you saying
he uh
so kevin garnett and then keep going
that's all that chatter [ __ ]
and then oh yeah so it says oh yeah
these catfish relevations were coming
out vivian was found huge cyrus so that
that co-host goes oh [ __ ]
uh vivian has been found alive and safe
thank you for all the help and
everyone's like nah dawg
so then they started investigating it
throughout all this nba twitter
detectives poured over the accounts
entire history of posting
looking for areas of sloppy catfishing
and then it popped up look at this very
bad photoshop
look at her pictures look at that
picture oh
who fell for this [ __ ] and then keep
going like lakers time
i'm crying there's no way she got away
with this look at her picture
no one no keep going down dog look at
this no
this is the best this is the best one so
keep going look at you're like
you see the picture right a little
suspect okay keep going
and then some guy goes how did nobody
figure out that she put her first name
on the back of
jersey
keep going photoshopping looking uh
yourself whooping overseas should be
punishable that's what he said overseas
so what does that mean
they see look there's the real lady
what that [ __ ]
yo she photoshopped her face yeah keep
going
whoever this is interesting keep going
this is the best catfishing thing since
that uh matteo on the
notre dame and then look do you all
realize how advanced we face technology
is these days look up the name sharon
alexey
so they take that who's a baddie takes
that model's face
this model look that's the real model so
they stole her face and put it on that
girl [ __ ]
and they showed a clip here and then
look he goes still haven't got a goddamn
explanation this is that co-host he's
trying to
because they think he's behind it all
right he was telling me i got a goddamn
exclamation thought i'd trust someone
and learn my lesson try to help a friend
i thought it was
in pearl i was duped like y'all and feel
bad i was upon such garbage logging off
for a while stay
safe out there you never know so that he
thought he'd be good
he thought it'd be good he's not good
he was i didn't address this earlier in
the day because i wanted to confirm with
vivian what happened
i didn't receive that i was also
protecting my mental health because
rumors spread like wildfire
uh thank you to everyone who reached out
keep going down
and then and then her profile pops up
the catfish is talking right yeah
y'all be on here hearing the side of the
story of one guy that automatically
assume he's right about everything
i have people on here can verify who i
am i don't need to prove anything to
anyone as far as me going missing yes it
happened i passed out from my treatment
remember [ __ ] she had cancer leukemia so
keep going
no dude this is insane oh it's so weird
keep going chin
pass this yeah keep going
yep hold on hold on so i'm gonna i'm
gonna let you all have you all fun
tonight get all the jokes off you want
on me when [ __ ] drops let's see who has
the last laugh enjoy the game
peace sign and apparently that's bam
at a bio they said that she posted like
an actual video
to prove it was her but it got deleted
right away so i didn't get to see the
video i was looking around for it yeah
it's nuts
and then there's jk she really not
um most 99.99 is not a real girl
keep scrolling down and then it says you
know scroll up chin it goes
it goes vivian uh just kind of goes away
for a bit as overwhelming
evidence pours in it's a catfish and the
theories are bound and the scroll down
because this guy put out curiosity i
pitched down vivian's voice from the
lakers podcast because they host a laker
all lakers podcast
you know uh lakers probably see what it
sounds like without any potential
effects that could be used to make it
sound high
pitched but people start looking into it
so it's pitch down
so they drop it lower right drop
detuning they
not wins that we won uh against teams
like the contenders
that obviously they think it's an
australian new zealand guy 100
i'm not mistaken both teams of bill 500
i think
yeah uh yeah so that was it so that's
not my
real voice yeah so then this guy sounds
like australian academy not that this
evidence or anything i'm just trying to
figure out if it's audio effects
and then he goes into it he goes for the
record i i'm a former audio engineer i'd
say the exercise has made me think it's
possible that the pitch shifting was
used but not guaranteed
pretty sure that pod is two different
people though unless it's really good
voices
keep scrolling down look me starting my
new laker spot
[Laughter]
oh so that's the podcast right there
it's a big problem yeah look
no but look reader when i suggest
someone record themselves in a modular
female voice to laugh at their own joke
but poorly clipped audio
and i tell you i'm tweeting this with
tears streaming down my face let me hear
you
now i've truly lived yeah listen this
like imagines the same guy fresh prince
of bel air carlton
chucking it from half court and uh
but he took a bunch of they took they
were taking a bunch of shots
like listen run you're off
that was it yo a little laughing between
so he can mix that laugh
as an audio engineer that's going to be
tough to do to do that so much work
yeah if it is it's possible it's such a
challenge
it might be just another person that's
not really that girl it's just another
person either it could be a guy or a
girl
or some guy who's a beast doing both
characters
recording ain't going bro he should be
you should probably audition for sound
i was just about to say i got xbox in
there you can hold it look hey do you
recognize this girl by chance because
it's the real girl look at this
oh that's the fake girl yep how long you
be in new york city for
okay i'll be waiting that's in 2009 yeah
it's the same girl using the same
profile
it's a big catfish account i went along
with 11 years ago to see how far would
go and expose them
the original impersonated model roberta
little under the name joanna peters
i contacted her agency a few times but
heard nothing back
and their podcast is just audio yes i
mean it has to be just audio that's just
audio but but all that work for audio
podcast is not you said killing like
that i don't
say they said it had three episodes so i
guess
some people subscribe to it this is like
a well-known i don't know about the
whole well-known thing i think they're
joking it's bar stool
yeah i think they're joking keep
scrolling down
new development video used to go by the
name of kelly little butterfly 88 and
was knee deep in the i'd say balls deep
and the raiders twitter this [ __ ] is
insane oh this was just time it was the
same girl yeah but she was doing it for
the [ __ ]
raiders raiders damn
so hold on how nuts is that yeah as of
now there's still plenty of questions
like i guess there's really only one
who's going to co-host the lakers
podcast with that guy josh
and well he or she or won't he or she be
an actual person how nuts is that
it's creepy it gives me the chills so
much work exhausting like [ __ ]
chill what he should just come out back
yo i've been doing both because
i can't find another co-host it's been
so much work i'd love a real podcast
host
but but why create a story that no one
asked for
leukemia the then he i think he didn't
know it was gonna be he wanted attention
he was like oh she's missing
get attention strictly that's when
people like huh even though they looked
into it
damn yeah that's just it a lot what
about
your deepest darkest suit
everything i'm glad i don't have no
twitter that sounded like a dude though
when they deeply
deep uh pitch the audio that was like an
australian isn't it crazy
well so they d pitched it to make it
sound like a dude if they put
pitched it back up to the normal thing
you would hear the voice but i'd rather
hear the actual normal voice oh there's
no sound
of the normal voice no this is called
twitter's [ __ ] right yeah twitter
detectives oh my gosh
at the end of the day my mind is just
[ __ ]
yeah that's how i feel right now but
that's how catfishing is because that's
why
because it's like a lot of people like
this you're like what the [ __ ]
but again i watch that show on mtv
catfish and it's just so much work
but people are really i can see somebody
sending money and people they've never
met
you see the one where he goes and meets
the girl and it's not her
she's like it's a big nose it's a big
girl bigger girl and then she goes uh
i got something else to tell you and
then she pulls out her eye you didn't
see that
no yeah now and it's like hey you don't
need to tell them that
i don't even care
you ever seen the one where it's it's
like uh the girl thinks she's talking to
a guy and they're like in love and she's
talking about moving away with them
and then they look more into it and it's
like her sister no
no yeah that's that's scary some of
those catfishes are [ __ ] insane it
was what would be like how much
how much money but guys probably three
thousand dollars over the last two years
and like
you've never faced i'm like no they have
bad service so they can't do it
even like you've never seen them in
person like no that's what they do we're
supposed to be at a park one time but
he said he couldn't make it yeah it's
just like we figure it out we webcam
figure it out but some people are just i
mean they fall in love so
i know it was one episode where she
people just want to be loved the guy got
catfished
and she like she didn't look like
anything like the picture but she was
bad
and he was so mad like you lied to me
and all that like she's hot but she was
bad but we'll also figure it out
he was like man i can't believe i'm i'm
betrayed right now he's all morbid
there's been one where a gay dude
catfish a regular dude in the regular
yeah
he was down to five he was out of fight
he was like nah man
hell no he almost wanted to fight you
dick pics
because you know nev got started because
he got catfished yes yes
the host you show me
because oh i didn't know that he has a
documentary called the catfish
and he and he was he was got catfish
like i bet there's a lot more people out
here and started the show
there has yeah yeah but you need to
watch that is that show still going on
yeah it is so yeah you have a new
co-host you remember the
same co-host the girl really thought she
was talking to bawwa
no oh you can't you know what i'm
talking about i've seen that one
you've never seen the one where uh they
like someone thought they were talking
like brad pitt
and neve was like i just i don't know
how much we gotta look into this but
i don't think it's brad pitt how can
they be no
like no i talk to him all the time it's
so crazy some people
use very popular like recognizable
people and they still get catfished
like there's this model on instagram she
goes by golden barbie her name's jasmine
oh she's
beautiful woman uh this catfish used her
photos
as like this girl and this guy's like no
it's her it's her
neve actually got the actual model on
facetime to talk to him she's like no
like i actually don't i'm not on social
media
sites that you're on right now like that
is the model
golden barbie yeah but she's like very
recognizable
uh-huh she's very popular oh okay she's
bad
super bad but yeah they facetimed her
and she's like no that's not me you're
getting catfished oh can it be
you damn well can i get you yeah she's
like
i want you what you think of me right
here right now
i'm real
hey forget who i was
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this from a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son